last year for example we have one
connecting art home and literature
humanities this year were very very
pleased to have
a text of work from music home to
humanities and CC sort of branching out
in various ways so I welcome you to that
I keep for those of you who are that how
much you've seen haven't yet taken music
honk this will prep you you know for a
more ease of music home so before I
introduce our speaker I also want to
tell you that we have we instituted last
year a new program called the core
Scholars Program which is exactly to the
point of making connections between the
parts of the core we encourage students
to write a comment for formative to that
one student last year proposed a piece
of music speaking of anyway any kind of
work of art any kind of kind of funky
interesting essay for example somebody
created a song called frontiers of
science is just that come in to once a
little ditty
anyway the dates for submits the
submission in these is the date is March
15 you have plenty of time to think
about this and regions can submit about
something that any anything really
anywhere come or any kind of work of art
a dance a video whatever that makes
connections between parts of the core a
group of students spend that the
sufficient last year we only chose four
and each one more awesome than the other
they're only website so you can see them
there but anyway we're encouraging
students already at this point you'd be
thinking about that and I think with us
persisting today will inspire you to be
thinking very creatively about the
relationship between music come in space
so it's really an enormous pleasure to
have the opportunity to introduce
professor even assist men who are just
going to know in the past few years as a
wonderfully very brilliant and committed
member of our community
professor systemin is the Anne Carson's
bender professor of music about if I
listed all the things that she's done
over the past 20 years that Columbia
would actually feel tired yourself so I
won't do that but she's chaired the
music department she's chairing music
humanities she has been like she and I
share various mornings together a few
years ago when we both served on the
Presidential Task Force and
undergraduate education professor
assessment is the author of many many
articles books I'll just name her books
the most prominent of them anyway hiding
in the classical variation another book
Mozart the Jupiter symphony and she
edited for example collection on high in
his world
she's also you don't feel you're witness
for her great teaching abilities in a
moment she also had won the great
Teacher Award she's won the Hamilton
medal and she's won she's had the award
for a distinguished service to the core
curriculum so I'm really really thankful
for professor system and for luxury now
one thing in respect to her respect to
the other people
please now I see I cut my finger out and
turn off your cellphone's okay all
devices we surely don't want to be in
the middle of hearing something like
Mozart and have the pastor listen to
your cell phone music okay so let me
give you a second to do that and in the
meantime let's welcome professor
assistant
it makes me tight with your words like
20 years it gives me great pleasure if
I'm not looking at a lot of textures I
don't think when I took my music
amenities class you might have felt in
the upper left spring I should came over
and said please tell you his last to
stop texting distracts people at the
Opera but don't you go thank you
Don Giovanni is close to my heart but it
was the first time I ever saw and I have
to tell you that I grew up thinking
Germany was a hero yes he went to hell
he was
but he didn't succeed with any of the
women to be actually persuaded however
temporarily on stage but I found him
riveting it was until I grew up that I
found that people were using words like
rapist murderer blasphemer thug to
describe dr. Bobby and I family somewhat
distressing the wand has also entered
our language in a way we refer to
someone as a Don Juan and when I asked
my classes who don't belong is or was
and what is a done one the only word I
ever hear is womanizer
which I always think that was like meat
tenderizer but what exactly does that
does that mean because Don Giovanni just
a player it's not entirely clear weird
the word has the idea has attenuated
findout to this easily sense but in
order to give you some sense of the
extraordinary literary tradition of Don
Giovanni and then focus on the way that
Mozart and his librettist Daponte
changed that tradition it's useful to
remember that there were two essential
things that a Don Juan story you have to
do one it had to show done one who was
in his original incarnation called the
trickster and would I would disagree
that he was a trickster above Seville he
loved through the labyrinth setups
he wasn't just
there was there was generally quite but
we'll see one of them in a wanna that
what he enjoyed was as he couldn't like
was a series of jests he wanted to amuse
himself all the time and he didn't want
things to be too easy but nonetheless
the idea of exerting persuasion was what
kept him going so we have to have a sort
of serial sense of these conquests and
then secondly he must be punished he
will in the course of his exploits kill
the father of one of these young women
and then he will for some reason invite
the statue in the grave of that man to
dinner and that would be the ancient
defense retribution statuary didn't send
him to hell so W money that one must
create in effect escapades or exploits
with women and then he must
yeah you see it served in the middle of
the page earlier plates there were
dozens even hundreds of Donilon plays
the very first one you need to come to
the stage was a Spanish monk who's
pending was tear septum arena
it was probably performed at least 20
years before its publication date about
1630s the date you have to establish and
woodland owners disappear could be Dido
two kids rather the point where the
beginning is that there was a a stone
guest that the statute came to dinner
and here succeeds with women over and
over plot devices meeting a young woman
clearing it with her fiance that he's
gonna marry her instead of the fiancee
clearing it with the parents clearing it
with her developing practically wedding
plans and then spending the night with
her superior so in many cases these
exploits required a promise of marriage
and the promise of marriage was in fact
something there was a basis for a
lawsuit called seduction by promise of
marriage and you could actually sue
someone who took advantage of you in
this way not that many people sued
anyone
partly because then you would have to
reveal what happened
so in effect one of the things they
don't want so successful is that women
had to keep quiet about their dishonor
often he would come to them
disguised as someone they knew or they
were expecting an assignation with their
lover or fiancee and he would arrive
first in the dark
the masked in a cloak and then they
would find that only
it had been the person they were
expecting so the idea of the serial
seduction but the punishment was always
significant and the month of course
wanted is done want to be a lot of fun
for people to see but also a moral tale
and that was how much I enjoyed watching
the persuasion ultimately it had to end
in 1665 Moliere wrote a comedy in which
he introduced a figure of a woman who
don't do money have done one have had
seduced away from a convent now in the
annals of sex crimes seducing a drug is
very bad it's very high on the list it
is worthy of damnation all by itself but
he declared her his wife and so in fact
there was a more serious past love
animal here and we also have here a Don
Juan who is a committed atheist and
influenced speeches about his its
philosophy and his beliefs the calming
servant is also present to the very end
of the play is angered when his master
goes to hell because who will pay him
the last words of that play my wages my
wages and then the third one that's of
interest to us is Karla Baldoni who was
more well known to the African history
because of the way he incorporated
aspects of
Romania commedia dell'arte into what
were called regular plays that they've
actually written texted plays not those
are unruly fun moving us up improvised
comedy and he also wrote many many
librettos for operas so he's important
theatrical and music history is Don
Giovanni 10 audio that was the name
actually don't want Tenorio was his last
name or the dissolute one the libertine
is it was not a libretto it was actually
a tragedy in fact and he tried to make
it less irrational as he put it he
thought it would be ridiculous for a
statue to appear in take doctor partly
to hell and so he thought it should be
just natural means and so in fact his
Don Giovanni says many come and strike
me dead if I am lying and a bolt of
lightning said so why that's less
supernatural than a statue appearing
like it gets slightly less supernatural
uh but this set of characters funny
rather interesting because they all seem
to be female that is the young woman
that his father he kills as mostly after
power and not love and there are new
takes on the characters but accompanying
done one in his trip down the a Tripoli
and literary history are the women who
come along and the kinds of set pieces
there's usually a woman named Joanna
lady Lady Anne there's a often in
Isabella there are sometimes in el vira
and they have somewhat different
attributes one has come from Naples to
Spain to get her to fulfill this promise
so everywhere they're willing to
compromise
and women therefore who are hiding the
truth from nigger friends whether his
fiancee's husband's because of the
disgrace this is one thing thing he
counts on by the time Mozart and de
Ponte got their hands on it in the 1780s
Don Juan was considered to baste story
it was fit only for improvised Street
Theater at fairgrounds pantomimes puppet
shows and it had a number of set pieces
that everybody expected everybody knew
that there would be at least one
nighttime escape from the ladies Becker
everyone knew that he would he would
kill the father generally the important
man in town often called a commander
everyone knew that there would be both
highborn lady seduced and a little more
ladies you have a noblewoman and a
peasant or a fisherman's wife someone
who was of the people and then finally
the bedroom escaped high and low women
and killing the father then finally they
were to the statue coming to dinner with
puppets I imagine it was rather amusing
I've seen some of the some of the texts
and if I may quote from Byron's Don
Julian from 1824 this is the way he
begins his satirical poem about he's
reflects the story he says that it's Don
Juan but you can tell from the rhyme
scheme that that's how much in common
Don Juan it's simply irresistible to
women he doesn't look for them
they find him and therefore he falls in
love in every at the same time he's
constantly being approached but Byron
begins his poem I want a hero an
uncommon want when every year in month
sets forth a new one till after cloying
the Gazette's would can't the age
discovers he is not the true one of such
as these I should not care to vote all
today other poor take our ancient friend
dong Xuan we all have seen him in the
pantomime sent to the devil somewhat
here this time and that sets the tone
for his home so it was a rather bold
choice for Mozart and Daponte to pick a
Don Juan tale for the court theatre in
in Vienna and what they were trying to
do was work with a genre that in fact
Goldoni had pioneered a way of writing
comedy that would bring the tragic the
serious the noble right today's front
door because it wasn't either a tragedy
or a comedy but something that would be
is sometimes uncomfortable mixture of a
tragedy comedy genre called the non
logic host it sounds sort of like
serious and comic not pure opera buffa
comic opera but something that would
have mixed sets of lovers Mozart's
librettist Lorenzo Da Ponte was a
fascinating man he was raised in Italy
where he studied literature rhetoric he
had memorized Dante's Inferno
early age he was a professor for a while
born Jewish father committed the family
to Catholicism when he took a second
white and the Ponte seems to have taken
some kind of minor Holy Orders in the
Catholic Church which appears never to
have lived up to in any way since he was
a good friend of Casanova and had a
series of exploits with women that rival
anything in the libretto he wrote before
Mozart
in fact shortly after they met both
Mozart and the Ponte it had been had the
police called on them before some
relationship they were conducting but
what duplicate came from I'll just say
ahead of the story defunding lived for
several years in Vienna has the chief
poet to the Imperial fears then has
changed
a woman cetera exhaust are leaving towns
one step ahead of the authorities with
an average husband in pursuit if you
went to England her while then he came
here up to New York where he was the
first professor battalion at Columbia
University today Te'o Beverly me is the
Lorenzo Da Ponte professor Italian at
Columbia and down in lower Manhattan
there is a short Street called Lorenzo
way which is where the first Opera House
the US was built in New York about under
case influence try living in
Pennsylvania New Jersey but he always
came back to to New York that he was
buried on East 11th Street in 1838 the
cemetery was plowed under and the
Romanians moved to Calvary Cemetery in
Queens which is hundred near the 59th
Street bridge
so the monday comes full circle to us at
the time in the 1780s he also wrote many
volumes of memoirs which tell wonderful
stories about his exploits they don't
tell us quite enough about Mozart and
some of what they tell us may or may not
be true but he was he and Mozart were
wonderful collaborators they wrote about
the marriage if he drove together then
Don Giovanni and then a couple of years
later was he fun today and they all take
I don't want to say a dim view of
marriage but they all say they all make
marriage into a kind of central problem
one thing that makes Daponte literary
background of interest in this in the
context of Don Giovanni is that he was
in 1787 at war month 3 librettos at the
same time for three of the main
composers in Vienna
Mozart martini so there and Salieri and
the Emperor said however that you can
write three letters at the same time
here's what it said to him I shall write
in the evening for Mozart imagining I am
reading the infared on mornings I shall
work from our team and pretend I'm
studying Peter Ark my afternoons will be
for Salieri
he is my Tasso so in fact Mozart for
Mozart he was writing through the dark
Hellfire driven dr. von
for Marty news run pastoral work the
tree of Diana and Salieri opera was an
adaptation of Beaumarchais and it was
like epic kind of story like whether
there's literal reference to Dante's
Inferno and Giovanni something that
people have actually studied and argue
that Leporello is opening lines are in
terms of Remo just drive scheme and one
big question is the contrapasso that is
the punishment that fits the crime which
would help because he actually going to
what does he seem to be describing what
he describes that the freezing the
burning the demons and the vortices the
swirling are there ways that one can see
which which repels is just a normal West
that's where I don't talk what does this
have to do some of the deeper and more
problematic the fraudulent seducers and
flatterers will all the way down in the
eighth circle the treacherous ninth
circle were the relationships are even
worse than that the seventh circle of
violence where blasphemers there's
certainly a moment of blasphemy more
than one in Don Giovanni so the
relationship of Don Giovanni's
punishment to Daponte is knowledge of
Dante is a significant aspect and there
are some who believe that Don Giovanni
between Don Giovanni and his servants
they commit ever reflect every one of
the seven deadly sins as well and
we can discuss which the pros are
overspent mother's so now if you look
again at the first page of the handout
22 attention to a couple of things
before we complex aspects of the story
come to life in the first place I've
tried to show two characters so with the
descriptions of the original libretto so
you can see the Don Giovanni is young
and extremely like sensuous have a
leader this makes it something of a
problem if you see an extremely
dissolute middle-aged man playing Don
Giovanni's the original Don Giovanni was
19 and from the single engraving of him
pretty good-looking then there's the
serious pair of lovers
that is there's noble noble people done
on that Don Octavio we could tell their
titles engaged on its pulp from its
esposa and she's very good promised
promised to do the wife of doppio and
her father the Commendatore they become
endemic is it a man of some either
military or civic responsibility then
there's Donna Elvira all we know her is
that she's a lady of war books abandoned
by Don Giovanni but or ghosts is mostly
very large conflict and this doubtless
is the trace of their because when el
vira shows up in town the first thing
she says to Don Giovanni is you promised
you swore to me you seduce me with
flattery you made love you and then you
declared you your life
yuki-onna to expose the same formulation
that you would use it to same as I now
pronounce you man - life is performative
language so that don't you buy me food
well I married her moreover she says and
then you left or goes after three days
when we come to the list of the women
that Don Giovanni's servantis
assiduously keeping a catalogue of his
conquests and those exactly how many in
each country - how many of each rank in
society how many blondes in watts
company in fact and so forth the total
would be 2065 it would be difficult for
him to spend three days with any of
those because he's not that and in that
sense three days represents a
significant commitment and does suggest
in fact that was his life then in the
comic end of the spectrum here Leporello
the classics osso bucco the comic based
character of rumbling servant who
nonetheless clearly lives vicariously
through jihad and helps him and exploits
everyone needs somebody to change
clothes way to help him do the elaborate
setups that he needs productions and
then the lowboy impaired considered the
comic pair surly no we meet them on the
day of their wedding so why they're not
called betrothed or married in the
libretto of may be a sign of class they
don't honor the president's bozo
betrothed and my sect I was only called
the El Montay beloved or lover of
Saruman even though they come in
so in fact we see three different stages
of a marriage process we see
onomatopoeia with formal that formally
therefore we promise to each other
el vira had been promised by from
giovani but now with reach of promise he
has abandoned her and she's coming here
to find him and then we meet young
couple on the day they're getting
married
does this mean the day they're
publicizing their wedding doesn't mean
the day they're simply having a party
it's unclear and partly unclear because
the would suppose I could be spouse or
fiance might Ito the same way so and we
view it is in the language make us
definitely sure and the action all takes
place pretty much in sync of a libretto
said the city in Spain but the long
history of the Peaceville so we could
say so go and I've given you a kind of
potted a very brief so that points
rather than the entire libretto but the
first thing you see is that it's a
picaresque story adventure to adventure
the first adventure is escaping from
Donna's bedroom
the second adventure is seeing beautiful
woman arriving in town hearing her bail
her anger who left her and her desire to
see him again
and make him come back or not tear out
his heart then she turns around you can
see
somebody's already known loses interest
and the third woman Serleena the day of
her wedding and these are three the
three people who are in effect gonna be
pursuing
don't divide any light nemec's like
Furies for the rest out but certainly
many actually persuades and we watch
them do it later in the day doctor party
to them revelers and the moment now the
women in effect show us or give us some
access to the driver striking qualities
of darkness and light and so what I want
to do first is play you just the
contrasting moments first things that
you would hear in the Opera House
because clearly in a kind of picaresque
heroic way don't you Von D whenever we
think of the nature that exploits is in
effect either heroic or comic figure in
a wonderful article called seduction of
betrayal Elizabeth Hardwick describes
the seducer as essentially a comic
figure yes he may be a rapist but the
context in which he operates is that of
comedy and in a sense comedy writ large
not a good one guffaws all the time and
musicologists in their current ways are
always trying to establish exactly how
far didn't issue these relationships go
what happens before the curtain goes up
we may have a chance to us
moment but in fact the woman from whose
bedroom escapes will soon be bereaved
because her father who challenged by
Shivani to a duel and will be killed so
that within the first few minutes we
moved from a kind of comic musical style
to something rather different
so the first notes of the overture
if this is the first thing you heard in
the Hoffman house you would not expect
it to be in her will okay time you would
imagine you start I read that some
musicians feel that even when they're
playing in the orchestra the first chord
and Don Giovanni is something that
strikes terror or or something some very
very harsh about feeling into their
breasts that in fact is a slow
introduction lasting only a man in half
and gives way to this
not nearly fast action-oriented
essentially like in comic but also
heroic it has the heroic fanfares it has
the sound of horns which are imperative
to show like someone who can weather
great deeds but they can make things
happen so ineffective you have dark and
light
we have tragedy and comedy and I want to
bring in one more strand of musical
style which we hear towards the end of
the first act and this has something to
do with Don Giovanni that is a freedom
of action that no one else has that he
whether life force but he represents a
sense of individual the individual actor
and the passage I'm just going to play
you appears when the three masqueraders
that is the three people after his blood
we've done under Tokyo and Serleena
who has agreed to sorry don't know
Bureau was his former wife they come in
many masks now if you're gonna mask what
does that mean it means that it's
carnival and you could be interventive
you don't have to be a mask only on
carnival day before Lent but in fact in
a kind of social situation
the minute you wore masks it meant none
of the normal rules of morality applied
- it was an Universal key go anywhere in
any way anywhere you liked and you can
see lots of behavior guides saying
husbands don't let your wives and
daughters go out with masks or where
they're going to be bastards
but when three masqueraders show up at
Don Giovanni's party he's delighted to
see them because it means they're
willing to join in the revelry they
don't know he doesn't know who they are
but the sign of the mask is the sign of
freedom and what they say he says
welcome charming - creators my house is
open to you because and the words he
uses are vive la vie better talk long
live Liberty and they respond to things
precious hospitality and they join them
in time and they sing because if you've
got a time long live Liberty over and
over and over again
and it goes on and on and on repeats
that text over and over in a rather
heroic and forceful manner moreover in
the key of C major which was coded the
key of light the key so the question is
what is it doing there there have been a
lot of interest in vienna and american
revolution many people in vienna
actually correspond to the benjamin
franklin when he was in france in the
1770s they were following the birth of
the american nation with interest it's
been pointed out of course 1787 is two
years before 1789 and possibly stirrings
in France are also horizon the question
is what does the ability to tell me how
broadly can we interpret it some writers
have said this is Mozart's album for for
freedom others say Don Giovanni is
basically saying anything goes and
rather than find an Italian counterpart
to anything notice they choose a
well-known phrase and that deliberately
to create that kind of
so you really don't know if this means
that don't you Bobby's own sense of
individuality Don Giovanni has no kind
of super abundant source of energy is
creating a certain amount of chaos
romantic chaos sexual chaos social chaos
wherever he goes or if this actually
it's a salvo but it also accompanies
people wearing masks so what I wanted to
see was the very beginning of the Opera
in which we switch back and forth
dark and light this one moves us from
light to dark it moves us from Leporello
the grumbling servant keeping watch
while Don Giovanni is inside with Dona
Ana we don't know what happens
and in fact motor and Daponte don't make
it easy for us to know what happens
because when honest Beyonce rushes out
they find the body of your father he
doesn't immediately say what happened
here in other versions of the story she
explains right away and in this version
of the story they deliberately make one
doubt her explanation which is he came
in I thought he was you she says
meaningfully
because we don't know what your
relationship with her fiance he's been
and then when she realizes her mistake
he has grabbed her and won't let her go
and she finally manages to escape from
them that reassures her fiance but it
happens 45 minutes later in the Opera
and you're not quite sure why she's
taking all this long time to tell them
and what she actually means by she
escaped from them when did she escape
from him and the 19th century actually
thought that Anna was truly in love with
Don Giovanni
that in fact this was basically a
compelling moment of her life and that
the reason she puts off marriage with
Donna Tavia for the entire recipe opera
sometimes the phases that she's mourning
her father sometimes it makes the
audience laugh made them laugh at the
new production the matter cheeky doesn't
over and over and even at the end of
they think something must be out but
can't it just be that she's mourning a
daughter who wants to carry on full
mourning process but you're going to see
Samuel really in that production from
Salzburg in the 1980s and he is wearing
a mask and the idea is does this mean
that he's sneaked into her bedroom
thinking once she sees the mask
she'll know these are the rules anything
goes and if she and if she doesn't want
to play along he's disappointed but
he'll leave but then she screams the
house down and brings out her father so
is that that she didn't understand the
rules and of course she was too modified
or was he in fact not actually thinking
of Carnival but thinking of seduction
and it's more forcible aspects so to the
first video
you probably came out with something to
look at little girl the hero and yet
because I was adorable ruffled shirt so
what we see here is again flicking the
switch from light to dark the comic
servant grumbling wanting to be his
master so we do see a kind of vicarious
relationship with dr. Bonnie you can
watch and then the question is if he is
challenged to a duel and doesn't want to
fight uh is it really murdered
dueling having its own rules and
although illegal not clear on the other
hand he agrees to feel like it too
because his pride is wounded that it
seems to be the only that seems to be to
fight a cold man but the old man seems
to suggest that he's a coward
maybe his pride won't tolerate that now
pride is a very serious serious sin and
it's possible that in his unwillingness
to yield the point insisting on fighting
overpower the father in it not very
convincing the choreographed swordfight
here this is another his his fate the
next scenes will introduce us to a
Europe well immediately thereafter the
time you'll find the body of her father
Fatah vo says it's okay I'll be your
husband again father to thereby not
giving her any air to to grieve and they
swear vengeance alvera
appears and is humiliated as she is
constantly throughout the Opera because
she's the only indisputably deflowered
woman on the stage she has no male
protector and thus she can be made a
figure of fun even though she's
seriously insincerely loves Don Giovanni
and ultimately by the aunt that only
wants to save his soul and keeps
something that he will repent even if he
won't come back to her so she's a
serious figure who gets mistreated and
it depends on the production how
seriously she's actually taken but here
Don Giovanni actually fears that she
might make trouble for him since she is
his she she was married to him and
moreover she was not not interested in
preserving her reputation so here the
question of Honor suddenly Don
Giovanni's entire system seems at risk
because she's willing to blow the
whistle she does I've lost all
discretion because he's saying such
people were really but what he does it
leaves the karela to show her the
catalog and this is where we can see
that Leporello wants to be like Giovanni
he is he's been faithfully compiling the
list and so what I'll be realizes that
don't deny me
that would bring greater ridicule on her
to pursue a man like this she tries to
port him instead and indeed when he
persuades Tamina the peasant girl on the
day of her way to go off with him she is
there to to pull the plug
I'm not going to show you that wonderful
bit of seduction but the rest of teeth
and the duet watch it around Amano when
dr. Bonnie takes dirty his hands and
says this is what we married it's a
beautiful piece of musical persuasion
ended only by the appearance ability or
otherwise Serena would have been would
have been lost now don't you only gives
orders for the party and the text for
this is at the bottom of your handout on
the right hand side he tells La Parrilla
prepared a feast until the wine makes
all heads real any girl bring some girls
and girls are fine and the key thing
here is when he sings let the dancing
meet without any order that is he's
trying to create chaos
so that seduction can happen
chaos here are many went fearfully I
hear howl on three different types of
dances and indeed that's what happens at
the end one fan all three different
orchestras on stage three different
meshing but not quite measured up dances
with different kinds of steps going on
and Amanda just disappeared on stage she
screams so I want you to if we can skip
the champagne it's 24 I just want you to
see this moment because it's important
in the conception of Don Giovanni and
misconception changes actually from
production to production so long ago
this area used to be taken its mark
presto H is extremely fast but it is
designed to be in effect his giving
orders to Leporello
who's trying to enlist Leporello the
future enjoyment and he's trying to show
how under the the normally orderly
fashion of society which is in fact
dance movements were among the most
orderly kind fountain kinds of pieces
they all had segments that repeated they
hadn't known choreography dances were
associated with specific social classes
on minuet was the courtly dance and the
other a bit more rustic dances instead
he's going to use this this ball as a
microcosm for social disorder and it's
under the covered
we'll be able to seduce but it used to
be something a little bit more slowly
than the cow and so sometimes don't do
honking sounds like pleasure to learn
ignore woman and sometimes it sounds
like an obsessive in the grip of
compulsion and it depends on on how it's
done this is shades more time
Oh
so what's interesting about that
musically is that there's no place for
Dutch upon it to breathe there's only
one measure of rest we've got to do
practically the whole thing taking
little gulps of air so in fact it does
it doesn't allow for a relaxed
conception and it's possible that that
Mozart was trying to show this character
as though gasping at what he's trying to
create but I also want to bring it at
this point on them show you two more
scenes from a different production I
want to say something about the way he
regarded this because the subsequent
history of the Darwin's story
Giovani himself all goes back to Mozart
virtually no one could consider the text
upon to have written and Mozart had
Kierkegaard said that he reacted to this
opera as though he were a young girl in
love he said he feels feminized by the
awkward because he suddenly understands
what it means to want to just be
completely overwhelmed he is ravished
he says the music has found its perfect
subject the ideal vehicle for expression
because it reflects the erotic sensuous
genius of dr. Vaughn me and only music
can express that erotic sensual is
genius oh it's a perfect melding of
subject matter and and artistic
and it's founded an overwhelming
experience after that in effect the Don
Juan story takes a much darker turn as a
poem like Nicolas leant out in which Don
Giovanni done one becomes I he despairs
because the women of whom he imposes his
vision find it unendurable and what is
that vision the vision is what you see
on the bottom left hand side the only
time in Mozart's opera Don Giovanni
actually expresses his philosophy
liberal is trying to get him to stop
fooling around with women because it's
putting his life in danger all the time
his lover Ellen's life don't you find
that says sweet women alone crazy man
why they're more necessary to me than
the thread I eat than the air I breathe
and use the heart to deceive the life
that is that the treacherous deceiver
really is it's all love this time to
finally to be faithful to one is to be
cruel to the others I know so generous
apart that I love every single one but
women who have no head for figures can't
calculate this call my good nature
deception I've never seen such a vast
good nature so by the way this statement
philosophies are almost exactly lifted
from O'Hare the whole year molire's
don't want says to bring the beginning
of the play or as it takes until the
beginning of Act two for us to learn
this this passage but I want to explore
this notion of the erotic sensuous
genius a bit by suggesting what music
can add to the story that certainly
could be acted with its various set
pieces
and setups and expectations we can where
we can really see the power of
persuasion the joy in creating into
something that is setting up a kind of
elaborate jest and Don Giovanni has
sometimes been called a chameleon people
look at this the Aria you just heard and
they say well that doesn't express his
individuality well actually it does
because if he's looking for social
experience that's that's a rather
remarkable statement but it's in his
moments of persuasion that it becomes
most truly himself and some of those are
highly original some writers claim that
he only imitates the music of others on
stage not so at the moment that we could
see this in particular is towards the
beginning of the back to when he is
preparing to seduce a woman we never see
someone who is not a character she's not
listed on this list she is the maid of
Don Alvaro
he has just lived her that day when L
fear has come to town he's decided is
going to serenade her so he's changing
clothes with Leporello because he says
that servant girl doesn't wanna go woman
and therefore he wants to wear though
his own servants was uh and you realize
that the way to do this is to get Alvaro
to leave the house leaving the maid
alone so that he can seduce her to make
her leave the house lo karela was
dressed now like Don Giovanni don't you
mind these things forgive me my love
earlier on I was wrong I'm coming back
to you a pendant and the text of this is
on the back
and he says first we see healthier like
yearning for him nobody she can't hurt
her too much and she sings the main
theme of this you know the problem of
Don Giovanni then share a very very
simple motif that just goes up and down
the scale it's a very repetitive figure
suggesting that the means of her recent
action are going to be very simple
don't Giovanni picks up her theme my
enjoyed healthy right of the alleged or
Romeo and then she picks she now has the
turning-around motif when he really
starts putting on it and he's got a
lover Ella which is stipulated in his
clothes as not closing at this as though
he were don't you buy it and we see in
fact that Donna is now going to unleash
the melody of the serenading that he's
planned for the main the great melody so
when he sings come down and joy of my
life to you will see that you're the one
myself doors then there's an interesting
agitated passage and then she gives in
well the karela laughs and is appalled
that she could be deluded again and he
says to javonni right after this
Universal bronze so here we see in
effect the trickster the seducer
persuader and he notices that when he
says there's nothing uglier than high
humidity nicoletto
nobody's more talented than I in
creating this kind of thing but the
persuasive power is that of the music
and then we will turn briefly in look
extremely short serenade that he does
sing to the maid though she never
appears because once again he is
interrupted this is a very recent
production from the blind born festival
and shows Gerald Finley has Don Giovanni
the setting it appears to be from the
costumes the 1950s and so he's radically
different looking than jovani radically
different stage set which is much more
abstract but the singing and the
persuade the persuasiveness and the
location of people on stage is really
wonderful and yields himself to its
serenade ways the other thing is that
the Leporello of this production
poppy ceremony is the is the current
mets Leporello
so you get to seeing that different
production so this is the Finley's disc
she
perhaps it's not an accident that I have
run out of time with the persuasive
doctor bonding in front of us rather
than going to hell
Don Giovanni after this point things
take a turn for the worse and the
graveyard where at the precise moment
that is telling Leporello exploits and
says that he actually had just been
flirting with one of La Parrilla zone
girlfriends lovers happened you just
tell me that was such a difference not
what differences big deal and lover
Ellis's belated what if it had been my
life so much the better says dr. Biden
ama and that moment we hear the voice of
the commendatory your laughter will stop
before dawn
so what is it is it the desecration of
the sacrament of marriage is it laughter
and therefore disturbing from the dead
not letting the every piece live apiece
which is affecting serious injunction
how many sacraments how many sins does
he commit and for what is he punished
never be now and why the original I
don't want play decide but he must ask
him to dinner and that when the statute
appears he then asks don giovanni to
dine with him it was always an effect in
the original he goes to the church and
there is the statute meant he is fed
beetles and vinegar before being sent to
hell
here he simply agrees to go with with
the statue takes his hand and rent in
twain description and there we hear that
the tragedy of the opening notes tests
come to fruition because here's what we
heard at the beginning
complex known as trombones a reliable
sound of the underworld the supernatural
the beyond so we thought that beginning
the opening notes were foreshadowed some
tragedy
now we're discovering that it's hard not
just tragedy so the mechanics of of
detonation are fairly fairly clear it's
just not clear what it is what are the
sentence what we could say what are not
just since that is he seems to be
sitting in every possible direction I
haven't hit the deadly ones and
murderers are
and seduction and rape there's a people
are still actually arguing over the
limits of seduction and there is
wonderful literature on historical
accounts of of rape but when we see the
figure of Don Giovanni yielding himself
to that kind of musical persuasion when
he seems to embody the desire in the way
I think that's quite wonderful
performance by Gerald Finley then we can
see where the Kierkegaard notion of the
perfect melding of subject and artistic
expression divided story telling of it
throughout the literary and
philosophical history of the story this
is where it met its most perfect
amalgamation thank you very much
I'm Matthew John the chair of CC and all
I wanted to say is that we don't have a
roving mic so let's just we'll take your
questions but you need to set up in and
bail them out as if you're
can you hear me
just to get the ball rolling a mystery
curious as the pom chair what people
think here and be 50 doesn't think about
this in your classes really but I'd like
to ask if there's an interpretation
analysis there's a interesting book
called love in the Western world by
Danny delusional or he talks about the
kind of design of jovani represented he
counters it with the kind of love to
Trista represents which is really
hopeless all-encompassing what's total
being love interest as old boys don't
divani
it's it's not exhibit that there is no
desire to know the other there's only
desire to experience pleasure so he may
think that he's that's going pleasure to
the other movie does not bestow it but
you know and the kind of love that he
represents is completely destructive of
the social orders since it must
destabilize everything that it touches
the social orders is based on some kind
of
and commitment and he can only find
theirs on the rock for example things
that he's not thinks that Don Juan is
really only interested in attached women
because his ideas to get there before
the husband Devore this is where
conquest
comes from but in an honor society of
course it's he must he wanted it's
impossible to imagine that he actually
lived somewhere and he seemed to have a
house in Seville and he has neighbors
and friends think how could this be but
he counts on everyone silence and the
nature of love therefore is I think it
actually changes with every woman that's
the persuasive come on you just heard
the serenade is entirely different from
I mean there's no promise of marriage
and of course if she hasn't come down
yet
hasn't seen her and in fact some of the
language is very full of do gallant on
it in Italian he's really he's talking
about the sweetness in her heart he
wasn't just mean in your heart but he's
it's so it's very direct in watch eater
in Milano it with Serleena he's actually
a promising marriage of the girls
wearing a wedding dress after all and so
he must he has to paint a picture in
their mind of an enduring kind of love
which they must somehow realize is it
possible to be kindled in him
and yet they seem not to be aware of
essential unreality of adultery so I'm
not really talking about supposed to the
bed people make make a line here
thanks the idea doc Yvonne is sort of
applauding this overflowing force of
chaos disorder and it's very full life
it strikes me and similar to this the
Indonesian concept and I don't know how
would you say that documenting relates
to God Isis I'm a Dionysus fan so I
think that the the idea that he is out
is fundamentally outside the society and
the unruly forces is something that the
women in here actually appreciated I
think that that you can interpret both
him and his music and his role in the
society in ways that go beyond look at
how extreme the deceiving the treating
all this way so that in effect we have
the mundane view offered by lover Ella
who attended mediating with the audience
but Don Giovanni himself does in fact
act like the gods even coming to a woman
in disguise is
comment
yes so I think that the and I mean I
think I can't remember if your charity
actually invokes Dionysus but but
there's there's enough literature Don
Giovanni that I think that concept is
there differently now than he had when
he was younger and how he's kind of
seeing Rania is this older more mature
character rather than this like reckless
making your own kid running around and I
was wondering if you could speak a
little to like how it doesn't give it
because of pride or is it just because
he's had enough of his life don't feel
guilty about it or
when you said heat we talked about
michael grandage the interviews of the
the director of the new production of
the new to ghana himself because the
director said that dr. bonnie does not
go to hell for seduction because then
everyone would be in hell and you just
make him a kind of dark and somewhat can
I figure I do not for a moment think
that Don Giovanni is tighter than a
novel we have to Nicolas that's the line
that their later versions actually is
and in Jordan Bernard Shaw's Man and
Superman John Tanner Argo is Don Juan
Tenorio gives it to an because she is
the life force she the woman the man is
the creative spirit but the woman who
let Leslie pursues the man and so he
must yield to that greater force so it's
flipping an unattended plane all shots
in this mr. Giovanni is why does he not
repent when he knows he will die and
there's the trace of tear so into
yourself it's always I have plenty of
time to repent today I don't have to
gods extending the credit basically I
don't have to continue to give in in
dafonte and Mozart he there is no
there's nothing that the commendatory
can offer him that would make life worth
living when his life is perfect the way
it is and but also it is pride that that
makes him refused to repent he won't
admit wrongdoing he's not a coward he
said in fact he says of course I'll go
to dinner with you because leper Ellis
said no no no he's too busy sorry I
can't come with you he says no no one
will ever accuse me of cowardice and so
again the same pride that caused him to
kill the mandatory
kicks in here but it's not even tempted
and in fact there's a recent trend in
DVDs to show Don Giovanni naked to the
waist bare my chest and have to come
with you whatever whatever you dish out
so there's no ennui there's no in fact
that's a sin he doesn't one of the seven
sins that he doesn't know sloth can't
keep it have a lot of like that going
like the energy so that's one reason
that people think that he is in fact
heroic but faced with not really death
but eternal torment stands for
I'm gonna ask a tsetse question going
back to be valid labor time and we know
I guess that Mozart was a basement right
and a lot of the libretto seems to be
you know moderately anti Noble right I
mean especially with an interchange with
Masetto for example okay it make you it
away its play okay but so so my question
would be in that people of the your
table
I mean it could be about political
freedom and political change or it could
just be about libertinism right but my
question is did the libertinism for
Mozart and Daponte have some sort of
connotation also of you know ferment in
order to bring about change so that you
think we're combining it both I mean it
could be taken either way that's a
really good point I think that there was
some of that in fact dafonte had
originally used the word in the very
first scene we still we saw whether dr.
von your fighting Leporello says this
deliberate libertine will be without
doing liberty know that word originally
had been violently no that's the
scoundrel will be my undoing
Mozart change to deliver tea so I think
he really wanted to emphasize right from
the very beginning that there was this
kind of antisocial or destabilizing
sexual force that you represent that he
wasn't just a bad actor but but that
something about his transformation of
the mores and I mean the in the
encyclopedia is kind of equivocal on on
Liberty not
so I think that I think Liberty could
certainly be taken that and in fact
there's a German translation from early
on instead of saying the ability retard
or something with the piight and it says
here they have time tires in here lives
a free spirit
wait I think it's a really nice
I have a long list there they're easy to
find other the let out home I know only
because she retired Stratus wrote a tone
poem his is done want tothis is full of
heroic themes and then meltingly
romantic interludes but ultimately in
that poem don't you buy them doesn't he
does what you ask me that is he despairs
and he allows himself to be killed in a
duel and his life just kind of tickles
out a bunch of little trills
and they serve here this apotheosis of
this melody after death people I have
not seen a novel by John Berger called G
that is currently
yes oh yes there's pushpins stone guests
and rimsky-korsakov's opera but there's
other people
so you had spoken a lot about a class in
between the different lovers in da
Giovanni and we see that a lot in little
tippy-toe especially between like the
page was also big compared to it like
growing Don Giovanni how exactly has
dismal starts views on class and
stratification how do they develop
throughout has different operas
especially with tip one day and then
later on to interesting skills I'm not
sure exactly
they're always throughout the history of
opera
well threat news you have comic opera
you always have characters of different
classes that was one of the big
differences between I mean serious talk
so-called opera seria you might have a
serpent but you wouldn't have you would
take an interest really in those in
those characters that the comic opera
really sometimes would exacerbate the
problem so that when Don Giovanni comes
to the wedding and presented every night
he threatens that don't he basically
says you better go off now or it'll be
trouble the servant also feeling
that he's underpaid
is common but the the situation in
Figueroa is different because Figaro is
not only the time of character but he's
obviously the smartest person I mean
he's he's he's the figures anybody that
is not the one who ultimately triumphs
since the women of different classes his
fiancee Susanna the countess who is
middle-class she had been elevated when
she married they're infected sabores or
capacious view of serpents in fact
outwit their masters Caribee know is to
be a page he's not a servant class
person he's hoping that elevate more
elevated earth but in fact you've got to
butting to touch upon the types you bet
the philandering account philandering
husband and you have Caribee know who's
maybe these a little cherub like like
Cupid and he is in fact but even
adolescent even love with everything
done so in a way you may well up there
ought to be like don't do money but it's
not clear the subsequent that want a
mozart collaboration which is cozy for
Tuesday takes a dim view of women's
fidelity and their class is never really
an issue I mean it's clear that there
are servant just
is it lead with the philosopher to make
the women think their fiance's are
leaving and then they come back in
disguise and are not recognized and all
that to prove that they will fall for
someone else very quickly and also the
sisters who are thus duped
they have no parents they have no sort
of social standing it's really unclear
do any of these people are only Don
Alfonso the philosopher seems to be a
nobleman and so the people are somewhat
deracinated if that's not clear however
that they're moving towards a position
of greater equality and in fact the
comic serpent is a stock character there
had always been we went back in the days
of improvised company somebody was a
doctor somebody was a clown that
somebody was a kind of servant people
people took on different roles it's not
clear that Mozart and Daponte are really
calling for greater equality and the
nobility or in the audience clearly an
enormous interest and appetite in clever
servants they didn't object to seeing
either dissolute no woman or or peasants
or servants who seemed somehow to
they're stationed again it's hard to
read because each hopper is different
even asked about the ding should be on
the same field in the Magic Flute there
is a prince I mean the hero is a prince
the heroine is the daughter of between
of the night and the now-deceased king
of the Sun some entities heard the
certain level of nobility but how
they're however in Masonic terms they're
all working towards spiritual nobility
as represented by the rostro and at the
realm of the rostro weeds are under his
slaves which is never clear exactly how
enlightened one is at any point
going back to that question about
literature I recently met Quaker City by
George memory which is kind of an
American as an american gothic novels
very sensational eyes and his
interpretation of this kind of Don
Giovanni his job to you are the
characters victims are he kinda makes
them represent this extract idea of
where really would and liberties are
often takes this female form and I was
wondering when you think about maybe
them if you can interpret the idea of
the evaluator maybe their self-identity
if it can be crafted a Pinot have the
proper forms may be there
she is liberty and freedom are a problem
as expressed here because certain one
character has the agency and ability to
have that freedom but he's not just
don't make himself a big hassle sitting
by the swimming pool he is invoking he's
constantly required other people to
share his idea of freedom shall we say
and that involves his vast good nature
to see because it means that in each
case he must make them a promise that so
in effect his freedom requires that he
and his conquests buy into the social
norms of marriage as an ideal moreover
they are clearly interested in him
because of his it's not really
good-looking and charming but he's
obviously won't be a powerful and he
offers in fact what he says to Selena is
that what kind your fate in that sense
the freedom is now the illusory it's a
mirage that he offers them but it's
based on a society that is quite ordered
and the subsequent perception would like
with the important thing to be married
wouldn't be necessarily free at all
and I think one can interpret what
conserves spending lots of circles in
the air around the kind of freedom that
he might represent but within the
context of the Opera he still has to
impose that illusion
no I I just I think this is such it was
such a wonderful lecture and if I Pamela
Smith and I were just already talking
about you know issues to do with CC and
history of philosophy and humanities so
this is a wonderfully successful
lecturer not just because it's
interesting and amusing and delightful
and I kept wanting to apply but also now
you know I'm going to go home today so I
want to take three people three groups
Tony I think is maybe gone already
but Tony comes a party Tony there she go
sitting in the dark over there again
thank you coming from Ranchi another
wonderful Corvette I want to thank the
tech people so thank you all very much
great books and relationally and we
could come to my classes to help me do
that sometimes and of course finally I
want to